you know everybody loves your
neighborhood teacher but no one wants to
pony up to pay us a salary where we can
survive
while teaching we're easy we wouldn't
have a shortage right it is a symptom of
the sick and fractured system of
Education I think I always had it in me
to become a teacher but I never wanted
teacher pay we're underfunded we have
less resources we're kind of expected to
give up of our time we're expected to go
the extra mile all the time without
being asked even if I can you know I
think that it's as important to guide
students through an education as it is
to help someone in the hospital who's
sick or uphold the law in a courtroom
there is a certain amount of
demonization of teachers that goes on
knowing how hard we work and knowing
what what's actually happening in a
classroom it's hard to hear people put
down your profession in somebody's class
is the next bio scientist in somebody's
class is the next Discoverer
it's so important that we renegotiate
what we think about teachers I would say
on a national level it's too much
politics involved in public education
there's too much money tied to policies
and ideas about what education should be
in how education should happen and
there's not a lot of actual educators in
that conversation which I find extremely
problematic if you look at the education
system the highest need students usually
have the lowest smallest amount of
resources it is difficult especially
when you teach in communities of color
or low-income communities they bring a
lot of trauma into the room if you have
students arriving every day
and their minds are elsewhere they don't
know where they're going to sleep at
night they're cold they're hungry their
stomachs are growling across-the-board
generally like they're not going to
drive I think when you talk to teachers
the thing that we're most frustrated
with in regards to our kids is the
amount of testing that they have to go
through we are testing children to death
and we're testing teachers to death 20
years ago we might have spent as much as
two weeks testing today in 2015 the
average number of weeks a child spends
taking tests can be up to six weeks and
it just seems like a reoccurring thing
it's just happening over and over again
let's try a new test let's try new
standards
let's mandate them let's see what
happens we've been putting band-aids and
we've been trying to backtrack and
replace parts why don't we look at a way
to create a more holistic education
which includes social emotional content
and curriculum oh the best part where do
I begin
oh the kids right the students the young
adults it's there the best part of the
job I wouldn't give it up for the world
it's it's the best choice I ever made
was to be a to be an eighth grade
English teacher for every teacher is
when you see that spark when you see a
student engage they're doing something
that they loved and they're good at it
and they feel confident they feel like
they found their place in the world
that's my favorite part the teacher I
worked for kind of mentored me and he
thought that I could be a good teacher
he was wrong I'm not a good teacher I'm
a great teacher ha ha the person sitting
in that room is teaching - our future is
teaching - the hope of a nation is
teaching to the the potential of a world
might we value that more as a society
might we value that more
you